the best of treatments you can have is  hijab as you can see behind me there's  some kind of suction noise what's the  suction noise  [Music]  yeah i always said you'll ask me is it  painful i said no but it's definitely  annoyingly ticklish  brothers and sisters you just saw me  complete a highly recommended sunnah of  the prophet peace be upon him which has  immense benefits and it was performed by  a professional brother brother ramis  who's been doing it for 20 plus years  he's just launched an online course  teaching a step-by-step guide how to do  hijab you guys can register now with a  50 discount at hijab.clinic  ali or click the link in the description  box below and sisters brothers and  sisters a full hyjama course which you  get certified tested and you can go out  and revive the sunnah yourself  so don't forget 50 off right now  brothers and sisters at hijab.clinic  ali don't miss it  you